[Música]
nós vamos fazer uma pergunta o que é que
acha que as pessoas adultas forma livre
e consentida podem ter relações sexuais
com outras pessoas adultas podem pôr a
mão no ar o que estamos todos de acordo
dois ou mais adultos forma livre
conscientizar podem ter relações sexuais
é isso que se passa na constituição ou
no trabalho sexual é uma pessoa especial
que eu prefiro usar a única diferença ou
diferença principal com relações sexuais
que dançam cruciais é que é uma troca
voluntária ou seja há uma quarta relação
sexual com o objetivo de lugo e outra
parte o objetivo de obter prazer ea
milhares de pessoas que o fazem
conheça algumas centenas de homens e
mulheres que gerem o seu negócio forma
autônoma publicitar os seus anúncios que
servem os seus clientes em apartamentos
em hotéis ou têm pensões de rua e que
não tem nem ganha explorá-las
é sobre isso que vai falar que não vai
falar sobre o caso que envolve crianças
ou adultos que estão corrigidos os casos
que envolvem menores de seis anos ou
adultos que não sente o seu
consentimento
são casos de crimes são casos que devem
ser precisos criminal e judicialmente e
os delinqüentes devem ser condenados
aliás acho que nem faz muito sentido
falar em prostituição infantil nas
repressão sexual crianças e mesmo no
caso da presidência da instituição da
multa que é forçada que é corrigida
também acho que é um caso criminal e por
sempre tantos indirectos substituição
voluntária e ficção sabe também não vai
falar sobre situações tráfico e
exploração sexual
a tendência é confundido constituição
com tráfico e exploração sexual
mas tomar todas as pessoas que fazem a
instituição província de tráfico e
exploração sexual
fundir a pequena parte com o esforço
todo
as investigações têm mostrado cai
portugal
o fenômeno do tráfico e à exploração
sexual e poucos possível graças ao filme
que não se identificam mas podem cruzar
e para terem uma noção do que eu já fui
eu quem vai dizer capital final não é
não é possível usar os dados do
observatório sobre tráfico de seres
humanos que é um organismo total
portugal reúne informação sobre questões
relacionadas com tráfico humano e que o
termo em torno das minhas ações que são
os últimos dados disponíveis indicam que
foram caio portugal confirmadas 108
vítimas de tráfico humano
quase todos para a exploração laboral
vítimas para a exploração sexual apenas
três
claro que gostava de ouvir uma única
vítima para justificar uma atuação
judicial o que não se justifica é que
haja todo um discurso e mails que são os
resultados do reinado a uma imagem fora
dos estereótipos em relação à
constituição
muitas vezes as pessoas tomam todas as
pessoas que estão na constituição como
vítimas indefesas misturadas que estou
mal espera que alguém que ganha salvar
mas isso também não correspondem a
relevar foi apenas mais um estereótipo
a maioria das pessoas que estão na
constituição não considera que é vítima
e considera que fez uma opção
claro que nós sabemos que nem toda a
gente tem as mesmas opções o mundo
extremamente justo a constrangimentos
estruturais como as desigualdades de
gênero e igualdade entre países ricos e
países pobres que fazem com tanta gente
tem aqui gráfica as desigualdades
econômicas desigualdades sócio culturais
sabemos que há uma diversidade de
constrangimentos que influencia na
decisão
mas quando nós começamos quando nós não
estávamos quando enquanto o investigador
entrevisto converso com as pessoas que
fazem trabalho sexual o que elas dizem
ser uma opção
uma opção com grava depois de assinadas
as vantagens e desvantagens que entrava
em uma atividade que é rentável mas que
é altamente estigmatizada e não é em
cima seus primeiros que vocês pensem com
vagens ver exatamente à mente quando
pensas uma pessoa que pensa e eu aposto
que a maioria de vocês pensam em uma
duas situações ou numa qualquer parte
uma mulher do mau aspecto e de minissaia
está numa esquina numa rua escura da
cidade que é muito provavelmente o botox
é experiente e com certeza tem alguém
espiral existem apenas são apenas dois
estereótipos são imagens simplificadas
que não refletem com rigor é realizado
há uma diversidade muito grande de
pessoas que estão no trabalho sexual
precisado pessoas de práticas e
experiências nem todas dentro de
experiências positivas mas nem toda a
gente tem experiências negativas e
trajetórias de vida não são só mulheres
não são só mulheres na rua ao homem o
trabalho sexual ea mulher estrangeiros
não só sobre esse gênero há também
muitas mulheres estrangeiras do trabalho
sexual sempre nossa imagem estereotipada
como nós pensarmos na instituição a
partir do ranking está na rua e eu digo
vos que os estudos que são os tais
efeitos acidentais e tentou estimar o
número de pessoas que estão no comércio
do sexo nos indicam que a pretensão da
rua apresentará apenas gente cerca 10 a
20% do total das pessoas que visitou e
quando nós pensarmos na mulher
estamos a esquecer os homens fazem
trabalho sexual são menos essa
minoritários na situação de emergência
mas apesar do susto os dados do estudo
foi feito em portugal que teve uma
amostra maior predador sexual o estudo
liderado pela professora sonia dias
eu não precisava de lisboa e que
entrevistaram 1040 trabalhador sexo
tanto enquanto as ruas como contexto do
interior
homens mulheres pessoa sttrans e que em
todo o país e encontrarão 10,2 por cento
de homens
e já agora 7802 trans e ainda estudos
indicam que noutros contextos esta
percentagem é ainda mais elevada tanto
quando o discurso fácil sobre a mulher
vítima um homem absorver esquece que é
uma percentagem de homens que estão no
trabalho sexual
vamos falar numa ideia também que tem
sido muito veiculado há cá em portugal
os momentos e khan
embora possa parecer a idéia é
presentemente uma lista
quando se analisa é fundo perceber que
ela tem tido consequências muito
negativas para as pessoas que fazem
trabalho sexual e que a idéia da
criminalização do cliente na suécia
desde 1999 que não é proibido o uso de
vender sexo mas é crime com processo é
ver que está na base desta lei é daqui
as pessoas que estão na constituição são
vítimas se a infecção e portanto
senhores são vítimas são vítimas de uma
pessoa absorva o cliente portanto vamos
criminalizar o seu comportamento
ela já foi adotada em outros países pois
foi assim o governo sueco tem falado
muito sobre o grande sucesso pensei
dessa lá e de como ela diminuiu a
prostituição mas tem havido evidências
muito fortes nomeadamente as
organizações não governamentais que
estão no terreno e trabalham todos os
dias com as pessoas falam demais sexual
e que indicam que esta lei coloca em
maior risco os próprios moradores sexo
qualquer link próprio windows 7 e que
aumentasse organizado à violência ao
estigma e à doença
outra idéia que nós temos é de que todas
as pessoas que te ver que todas as
pessoas que estão no trabalho sexual são
são são vítimas
a rã é uma idéia simples e sem grande
inspiração em piqué quando se ouvem os
percursos das pessoas
os discursos das pessoas e este evento o
cliente é um criminoso
mas aí que parece biologicamente em
visava até porque as investigações ainda
mostravam que as moções de entre
trabalhadores do sexo e seus clientes
são relações complexas e que
maioritariamente nós são relações
abusivas
mas há um tipo de cliente que acho que
mostra perfeitamente com esta lei
esta eletrônicos aos clientes e desumana
são as pessoas que são portadoras
decência ou pessoas com necessidade
funcional outro tipo de diversidade como
é mais correcto dizer e que recorrem a
profissionais de sexo sexo levava é um
direito humano
as pessoas que têm deficiência têm
direito à sua secção de lado e ao seu
projecto e muitas delas só consegue
fazer correndo profissionais do sexo
até isso está em minha figura uma figura
legal que é assistente sexual que é
alguém que ser trem pra saber como ter
relações sexuais com pessoas que são
portadoras de deficiência
eu acho que este exemplo é bastante
popular sobre a relevância social desse
trabalho sobre a relevância do trabalho
sexual
e já agora destrói qualquer argumento
que tente que seja a favor da
criminalização dos clientes
então se as pessoas podem fazer isto
como uma opção
as pessoas acham que para elas é a
melhor opção naquele momento da sua vida
pra você faz aos seus as suas
necessidades econômicas porque nós
continuamos se isto pode ser feito vocês
pode ser feito sem violência pode ser
feito com control sobre as condições de
trabalho
se isto pode ser feito e mais exploração
do que noutra actividade laboral porque
nós continuamos é combinar tom
fortemente as pessoas que fazem trabalho
sexual porque este time é tão intenso e
tão forte sobre as pessoas que fazem a
sua actividade porque nós continua
eu digo espetar trabalhador sexo e minha
resposta é por causa da moral
especificamente a moral sexual de vida
sexual em dois títulos
blatter na sexualidade é considerada
legítima normal e natural e produz lá
temos uma sexualidade é considerada
ilegítima é normal antinatural e aí que
situa o comércio do sexo e o facto do
mesmo sexo é considerado ilegítimo um
anormal e anti natural está na base
deste uma desatenção da rejeição social
da descredibilização da sanção da
desvalorização das pessoas que fazem
esta actividade o estigma é uma marca
com ferro descreve de fundo o estigma
kaká substituído por sexo é fortíssima e
tem muitas consequências última humaniza
o estigma é uma forma violência está na
base de tanta discriminação sobre
servidor sexo com por exemplo quando se
dirigem a instituições na área da ação
da justiça e da segurança social e são
tratados com o conceito e vou ver isso
de outra forma
agora o casamento que não sei se alguma
vez alguém usou essa palavra não telex
vez o estigma de [ __ ] é o pior pode cair
sobre uma mulher
os pior ofensa que nós podemos dirigir
de maneira chamado [ __ ] o estigma de
lutas das mulheres em dois tipos as
honras e as narradas as sérias e as mãos
sérias
acho que exportam bem e exportam mal e
nesse sentido o estigma de [ __ ] é o mas
num instrumento está ao serviço do
controle da sexualidade feminina é uma
espécie de espada de moxos que está por
cima da cabeça de qualquer um de nós
qualquer mulher sabe se tiver um
comportamento sexual que se diz vidas
norma inscrição da escrita é socialmente
corre o risco de ver um ser que eu
executei do estigma disputa qualquer
mulher satirizar o trecho você chamada
[ __ ]
então qual o que eu acho que nós
pensamos
qualquer um nós pode fazer para que não
continuem a desrespeitar o historiador
sexo
eu acho que o caminho é dos direitos
humanos de todos e todas incluindo as
pessoas fazem trabalho sexual é o
caminho também de construção de
políticas baseadas em evidências
científicas já foi bastante falado aqui
de manhã em evidência científica e
empírica e não políticas construídas a
partir de pressupostos ideológicos
é também a conhecer este grupo como o
grupo tem sido historicamente oprimido e
lutar contra o fim dessa opção é
desafiar estima começou a fazer neste
momento ea dar voz ou vídeos trabalhador
sexo dar voz a um grupo que tem sido
alvo das mais tentativas dos mais vis
tentativas de silenciamento ao longo do
tempo o jogador sexo tão por todo mundo
organizados nos anos 70 mas mais
precisamente por causa do estigma e sua
voz não é não tem que ter cuidado não
são ouvidos não se soube dizer nós não
queremos compaixão nem crimes durante a
nós queremos direitos e é isso que eu
acho que também temos de ser depois
disso tudo
e para terminar acho que faz sentido que
é natural que devemos continuar a
desrespeitar a gente tenha uma pesar ea
criminalizar salvador sexo
obrigado
[Aplausos]